whereas to represent the inequality y is
greater than 5 on a number line and on
the coordinate plane so let's do the
number line first let me just draw out a
number line
that's my number line all the possible
values of y let's make that zero on the
number line we could obviously go into
the negative into negative numbers but
we're going to be greater than five so
i'll focus on the positive side so let's
say that's one two three four
five
one two three four five and then that's
six seven so forth and so on y is and
this number line represents y and y is
going to be greater than five not
greater than or equal to so we're not
going to be e we're not going to be
including five in the numbers that can
be y
so we're not going to include five so
we're going to do it open circle around
five and all of the other values greater
than five will be included
so
if there was a greater than or equal to
sign we would have filled it in but
since it's just greater than we're not
including the five so that's we've
represented it on the number line so
let's do the same thing on the
coordinate plane so let me draw a
coordinate plane here
and just using the standard convention
that is my y-axis
right there and then the horizontal axis
i'll just assume is my x-axis
is my x-axis
and let me draw some y-values positive
y-values 1 two three four five
that is five right there and you go six
seven you can just keep going into
larger and larger numbers and we want y
to be greater than five so it's not
going to be greater than or equal to so
we're not going to include 5. so at 5 at
y is equal to 5 we will draw a dotted
line
that shows that we're not including
that shows that we are not including y
is equal to 5
but we want to include all of the other
values greater than five so that we will
shade in so here we have shaded in
all of the values
greater than five it was greater than or
equal to five we would have drawn a bold
line over here so no matter what x is no
matter what x we pick y is going to be
greater than 5.